f1 you know f1 testing was this weekend
what does that mean it means lewis
hamilton uh
tested positive for not inserting
into any goblins
i'm just trying to think of phrases for
like ugly people which is mean
chocolate is pretty good yeah yeah i
said troglodyte earlier but
we're redoing the bit guys just for you
lewis hamilton positively
not [ __ ] any troglodytes this weekend
that's actually what it says on the f1
app
lewis hamilton shows great pace this
weekend he's positively not having sex
with any troglodytes this weekend
absolutely not
he made sure to reissu he made sure to
reassure espn
uk that he's only having sex with
absolute dime pieces
that sounds like michael keaton doesn't
it or [ __ ] yeah
batman yeah absolute darn pieces
absolutely darn pieces bro he
he actually did not do great in testing
this weekend so you know
maybe maybe that's the problem maybe
maybe he's left with an eight
and it's just [ __ ] his whole world up
it's throwing him off completely
yeah he went back into the who am i
he she goes to therapy for it i just
i'm so lost doc i mean i i
what happened i just i keep i have no
place i [ __ ] an eight i've not placed
these lips
on a breast any smaller than a d cup
in eight years
i don't that's not a d cups not even
necessarily make you a ten i'm just
i'm getting into weird territory now
look now you got these you got was
these these
double double d's nuts oh in your mouth
yeah i i feel like um you're lagging
again
but it's fine i know and we're live
farting
partying okay sorry we had to [ __ ]
fix some technical difficulties but
we're back
and uh what were we talking about uh
michael michael
keaton michael king michael michael
keaton sucking on double d
titties or something like that yeah
we're just you know god we're joking
about it
oh yeah right yeah louis you look great
out there this weekend what are you
feeling
i feel like i'm gonna go right off track
and
have a copious amounts of sex this
weekend
i'm going to i'm going to have egregious
amounts of sex
with you look great out here on track
today
[Laughter]
tell us what are your plans for the
weekend
i don't know really didn't get my balls
sucked
probably gonna have my ass eaten
honestly
probably going to have my ass eaten you
ever done this before
no lewis afraid not afraid of not here
at bbc sky we can't say that
you have to change [ __ ] you never had
your ass eaten before
your [ __ ] last name is eaten
i'm telling you let her put a little
finger in there
it feels quite nice
just a little bit call me michael eaton
tonight
[Laughter]
is that's what's on that's what i'm
gonna do to your
ass call me michael ate
i can't even really do his voice but
bruce
[Laughter]
monster bruce
[Music]
call me michael eaton
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
master wayne they don't call me michael
eaton for nothing
are you good at eating ass like i
can't be i could learn
for you master way anything for you
master wayne i'll learn
i'll change my name to michael eaton
that is so stupid holy [ __ ]
louis in the pit dude saying i'm gonna
get my ass eaten this weekend is so good
[Laughter]
yeah what can i say feel pretty good
wins podium
walks off big-ass bottle of champagne
louis how are you going to celebrate i'm
going to get my ass eaten
i'm going to go get my ass
[Laughter]
i'm eaten fall on my back like a dog
lift my legs in the air
wrap my hands around the back of my
knees and get my arse eaten
i'm gonna go get my salad tossed
honestly
if you want me to be honest
uh i'm gonna go get my arse eating like
a goddamn creme brulee
it's like it's like borderline
australian
i'm gonna go get my rc you've got a
creme brulee
like like a goddamn
like a go goddamn muesli
you give me [ __ ] ass eating
goddamn [ __ ] you want to [ __ ] eat
my ass
be my arse
[Laughter]
i don't know i don't know man oh brother
i'm gonna get my [ __ ] arse eating
um ah you wanna try another accent
um mate i wanna get my [ __ ] arse
eating
oh shush hide oh [ __ ] get my arse eaten
i'll be saying how do you think happy
saint patty's day by the way
how are you going to celebrate noel i'm
going to get my crack eaten wide open
[Laughter]
i'm gonna have the shite eaten out of my
ass
i want
i want to find me a nice lassi to
shuffle the poop shovel
the shade out of me crack with her
[Laughter]
tongue
[Laughter]
out of me bum my bum you suck the poo
out
man i miss imagine luke and kyle sitting
there right now it's like
why work for these guys we work for
these guys
this is real life sorry we worked for
these guys listen kyle i'm sorry but
oh god oh
he's gonna i gotta find me alas a lucky
class to eat the
lucky charms out of my butt
oh my god oh find me a nice lassie to
lick the
dong they're after me dingleberries
they're after me chocolate chips
[Laughter]
no luke is laughing kyle went to like a
good school that's why we're not funny
to kyle
kyle's actually smart he's like oh yeah
yeah my job is babysitting
three-year-olds yeah
so they can say poop and dung into
microphones for a living
oh man hey find me how do i see the
shovel of the poop out of me duncan
happy saint patty's day by the way yeah
by the way this is like very high brow
intellectual humor this is a meadow
yes please turn this podcast off if
you're not
if you're not here for hot takes and um
very poignant observations
yeah this is actually a meta commentary
here on the
um insensitive nature of the lucky
charms caricature
yes yes i think it's ti
i think it's high time that leprechaun
was cancelled